il était là sauf erreur monsieur
Drainville bonsoir bonsoir Patrice vous
étiez là il y a 10 ans
est-ce que on a assez réfléchie d'après
vous à ce qui s'est passé là c'est un
tribunal civil qui vient donner des
sérieux coups sur les doigts aux
policiers est-ce que et SPVM il y a pas
eu d'autres formes d'enquête oui il a
inscrit a fait un travail on dit qu'ils
avaient changé les choses mais ce qu'on
a assez réfléchi à la gravité de ce qui
est arrivé ce soir
pas sûr
moi j'étais là avec ma femme et ma fille
Rosalie d'ailleurs Rosalie et Martine
étaient du côté de l'escalier donc du
côté de l'entrée où il y aurait dû il y
aurait pu arriver avec avec son arme
moi j'étais de l'autre côté de la scène
mais c'est sûr que si il était rentré
par la porte
là où il y a lancé le cocktail là où il
y a battu monsieur Blanchet depuis
courage si était rentré par cette porte
là Patrice il y avait ouvert le feu sur
la sur la foule
moi je
à toutes les fois que je repense à ça je
me dis je sais pas ce qui serait arrivé
à ma fille et à Martine et moi je vais
vous dire ce qui me trouve encore
aujourd'hui c'est c'est comme si quand
c'est arrivé c'est comme si comme
société on avait comme pas vraiment
voulu voir ce qui s'était produit on a
comme un peu mis ça de côté on était je
sais pas on voulait pas utiliser le mot
tact terroriste par exemple
c'est comme si il y avait une espèce de
gêne collective autour de ce qui s'est
produit et honnêtement moi je pense
qu'on l'a vraiment échappé belle ça
aurait pu être un carnage ce soir-là et
j'espère Patrice que les corps policiers
ont fait un méchant débriefing et
j'espère que ça ne se reproduira plus
jamais
madame Marois d'ailleurs avait dit
plusieurs années plus tard
j'aurais peut-être dû en parler plus
parce que elle-même voulait peut-être
pas trop à pleurer voulait pas en
remettre se disait bon ben on va faut
pas accéder à la panique etc on continue
à gouverner dans son cas mais elle avait
quelques regrets là-dessus en disant il
fallait peut-être faire un arrêt puis
faire une vraie enquête pourquoi il y a
pas eu plus de il y avait eu des menaces
en plus reçu peu de temps avant une
vraie enquête pour que ça n'arrive plus
quoi mais je vais vous dire Patrice même
à l'interne on en parle presque pas
je me rappelle je suis allé on est allé
madame Marois était là bien entendu on
est allé au funérailles de ni Blanchette
dans les jours qui ont suivi c'est comme
si on avait voulu mettre ça de côté
parce que c'est un nouveau gouvernement
la première femme première ministre on
voulait comme
oublier ce qui s'était passé c'est comme
si on voulait tourner la page puis
comment fouir ça quelque part dans un
coin puis pas voir puis juste comme
penser à la suite des choses à l'avenir
puis au gouvernement puis tout ça mais
avec le recul
je sais pas si on a bien si on a bien
fait effectivement d'enfouir ça là
je souligne d'ailleurs que votre
collègue maintenant qui était ma
collègue alors martine Biron une soirée
électorale elle était dans la ruelle et
on avait donc elle a vécu ça on a vécu
ça ensemble donc traumatisme OK
les vapeurs de descente de ce soir là
moi je les ai encore je les ai encore
dans le cerveau là je quand je repense à
cette soirée là puis j'ai encore le
l'odeur très présente de l'essence que à
laquelle il a mis le feu
c'est ce qui part en dernier la mémoire
reliée aux odeurs c'est ce qui part en
dernier des études là-dessus mais là je
suis loin mais je suis loin oui et non
parler de vapeur
vous avez fait une conférence de presse
aujourd'hui en disant le sujet de la
qualité de l'air dans les classes et le
sujet le plus important pour moi sur mon
bureau là on va on va regarder un
tableau
il y a 724 classes problématiques
plancha comme ça c'est 1% des 68000
classes mais il y en a 72 très
problématiques où il y a plus que 2000
parties par millions de CO2 dans les
classes les 72 premières questions que
je voudrais allez-vous donner la liste
pour que les parents sachent chez eux
mais je n'ai pas la liste moi
moi j'ai des centres de services
scolaire une liste partielle des centres
de service scolaire mais j'ai pas la
liste et je sais pas Patrice honnêtement
je suis très
je suis en réflexion là-dessus parce que
je veux pas tu sais le message
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire dans la vaste
majorité la 99% des classes on est en
dessous de 1500 je répète que c'est une
norme adéquate sécuritaire c'est pas la
norme idéale moi j'aimerais ça qu'on
soit en dessous de 1000 partout au
Québec mais en tout cas on est en
dessous de 1500 pour 99% des classes
pour les 8 premières semaines de l'année
et puis là 1% qui reste on s'en occupe
j'ai donné des directives très claires
il y a des échangeurs qui sont
disponibles pitié les lecteurs de CO2
dans chacune de ces classes là parce
qu'on les essuie en
temps réel bon puis on a mis 400
millions pour la ventilation il y a un
autre 200 millions sur la table pour
dire au centre de service scolaire Hawaï
régler le problème ça prend les
changeurs fais-le s'il faut faire des
travaux fêlés s'il y a une ventilation
mécanique qui peut être installé fait là
mais d'aller dévoiler les noms des
écoles Patrice je suis pas sûr que c'est
la bonne idée actuellement dans la
mesure où on gère le problème
je suis pas sûr que c'est une bonne idée
de dire aux parents dans tel et tel coin
du Québec savez-vous quoi
j'ai un malaise par rapport à ça
maintenant mais le dire et de dire il y
a des moyens en attendant on va être
obligé d'ouvrir les fenêtres n'est-ce
pas ah mais on les ouvre déjà les
fenêtres moi je fais une tournée des
écoles depuis que je suis ministre puis
les fenêtres ils sont ouvertes puis les
enseignants puis les enseignants
honnêtement ils sont devenus bons ils
ont développé ce réflexe là pendant la
covid il y en a qui ont le réflexe de
regarder une fois de temps en temps le
lecteur de CO2 dans les classes parce
que maintenant on a un lecteur de CO2
dans toutes les classes du Québec alors
tu peux suivre en temps réel la qualité
d'air dans ta classe et les enseignants
de les enseignants maintenant c'est
devenu une seconde nature ils ouvrent
les fenêtres ils a juste la l'ouverture
des fenêtres selon la température
extérieure et tout ça donc vous dites
c'est pas enfin vous savez pas vous êtes
pas sûr c'est une bonne idée de dévoiler
le nom des 72 classes et donc des écoles
permettez-moi d'être en réflexion
là-dessus Patrice permettez-moi d'être
en réflexion mais ce que je peux vous
dire par contre c'est que
vous avez dit en intro puis je vous fais
pas de reproche c'est c'est mon dossier
le plus important ce que j'ai dit
aujourd'hui j'ai dit c'est le dossier
qui m'a pris le plus de temps pour ceux
que c'est le plus important parce que
honnêtement dans les écoles vous avez
bien fait vous aviez des vous avez bien
fait de m'écouter je m'en allais dans
l'autre question parce que des dossiers
il me semble en plus fondamentaux que ça
là quand même d'autant plus vous avez
raison d'autant plus que quand je fais
mes visites d'école puis je vous compte
pas les membrés là
un enseignant qui me parle de
ventilation jusqu'à maintenant il y a
personne qui m'en a parlé c'est moi qui
leur en parle ou c'est moi qui va dans
la lecture je vous le dis là c'est comme
régler dans l'esprit du corps enseignant
puis des équipes école mais je vous
soumets Bernard drinville que si vous
rendiez publique j'imagine on va déjà
faire des demandes d'accès à
l'information c'est la transparence
est-ce que de plus simple finalement si
vous rendiez publique ce que ça ferait
c'est que ça presserait le pas encore
aux commissions scolaires enfin ce que
remplacer pour régler les problèmes non
peut-être comme je vous dis j'ai pas
pris de décision encore là dessus mais
en même temps je vais être bien bain
franc avec vous Patrice
il y a des écoles qui sont
tellement mal foutu que
je sais même pas si ça peut se régler
dans certains cas bien précis puis je
vous dis le chouchou je suis pas un
expert à la matière mais je veux dire
j'en ai passé des heures là dessus il y
a certaines écoles dépendamment de
l'angle face au vent puis dépendamment
de l'espèce de
de la situation dans laquelle ils sont
ils sont dans laquelle le bâtiment est
placé
apparemment c'est extrêmement difficile
dans ce bon coin de ces cas-là de
descendre de faire descendre le taux de
CO2 ça devient extrêmement difficile on
fait quoi là
pour construire des nouvelles écoles
pour rénover les écoles pour faire des
travaux dans école on a écrit c'était 9
milliards le budget quand on est arrivé
le fameux PQI là sur 10 ans on est rendu
à 21 milliards on va l'augmenter encore
je veux dire on est à fond la caisse sur
bon la rénovation puis les travaux puis
tout ça et malheureusement on est pris
avec un
héritage qui date de plusieurs dizaines
d'années d'accord on s'en est pas assez
occupé de ces écoles là puis là on est
en train de payer pour et puis c'est pas
aux enfants de payer pour ça Patrice
vous avez absolument raison donc je
cherche des solutions puis je vais vous
dire je me creuse les ménages et vous
allez comme ça régulièrement tenir aux
gens courants du nombre de classes etc
c'est un exercice aujourd'hui c'est que
je vais pas attendu
rapport puis le prochain je souhaite
faire la même le même exercice en
espérant qu'il y aura des progrès mais
je vous le dis tout de suite avec les
froids qui s'en viennent il va falloir
les ouvrir les fenêtres un peu plus puis
il faut maintenir l'équilibre entre la
qualité de la puis la température dans
les classes pas sûr qu'on va être
j'espère que ça va aller dans le bon
sens la prochaine fois avant de nous
laisser aller parce que justement vous
avez raison vous avez vu un gros point
d'interrogation quand j'ai commencé en
disant il le dit que c'est le dossier le
plus important j'espère que c'est pas le
dossier le plus important sur votre
bureau il y a le manque d'enseignants il
y a l'école à trois vitesses qui
inquiète beaucoup de gens il y a des
écoles les traditionnels qui ont pas de
projet spéciaux se retrouvent un peu
délaissé
le plus gros défi là
quand je rentre puisque j'en ai fait des
écoles puis est-ce que vous voulez il me
raconte à peu près tous la même histoire
d'une école à l'autre là je vous parle
c'est presque exclusivement des écoles
publiques la composition de la classe
Patrice est devenu extrêmement exigeante
on a décidé c'est un choix de société
qu'on a fait ça d'intégrer les élèves a
besoin particulier dans les classes
régulières je remets pas ça en question
je le dis d'emblée mais on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec des classes dans
lesquelles il y a trois quatre parfois
cinq parfois six élèves
HDA donc difficile d'adaptation
d'apprentissage des enfants qui sont
autistes des enfants qui souffrent
d'anxiété beaucoup depuis la covid dans
sa montée dans certains cas c'est
troubles de comportement alors les
enseignants et les enseignants sont
beaucoup beaucoup absorbé
besoin et ils ont besoin d'aide parce
que ils sont pas capables de s'occuper
du reste de la classe ça c'est votre
priorité donc ça se concrétise comment
en terminant comment on peut les mieux
les appuyer les enseignants et les
enseignants ben je comprends encore à
vous dire exactement ce sera quoi mais
je peux vous dire une chose il y a un
projet pilote actuellement qui est en
place dans 100 classes du Québec
sans clan sur cette école sans école
pardonnez-moi 100 écoles du Québec et ce
qu'on fait les éducatrices en service de
garde là vous savez celle qui reçoivent
les enfants le matin quand ils arrivent
à l'école ils sont avec les enfants le
midi pendant le repas et qui sont avec
les enfants à la fin de la journée entre
le matin et le midi puis le midi et la
fin de la journée ils ont des heures ces
éducatrices elles connaissent très bien
les enfants et le projet pilote vise à
prendre ses éducatrices et à les amener
dans la classe comme aide de classe donc
on se retrouve avec deux adultes dans la
classe et là les enseignantes le
feedback qu'on a jusqu'à maintenant là
par rapport à ce projet pilote puis par
rapport aux discussions que j'ai dans ma
petite tournée parce que je demande aux
enseignants moi je dis si vous aviez une
aide de classe mais par exemple une
éducatrice en service de garde est-ce
que ça vous aiderait et c'est
universellement la réponse c'est oui bon
ça nous aiderait voilà un exemple
concret Bernard drinville merci et vous
vous l'avez dit je le répète il y a
personne dans votre tournée des classes
qui vous ont parlé la qualité de l'air
le moment il faut aussi
parler des priorités des parents des
enseignants aussi ou si ouais mais ça je
suis content de vous l'entendre dire
Patrice
il faut que j'en occuper je vous demande
même de rendre public la liste mais on
s'entend je pense que les gens on
s'entend ça arrive souvent qu'on
s'entendent
salut bonne fin de semaine salut à la
prochaine pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]